-Welcome back, everyone.
We are talking to the
one-and-only Daniel Craig!
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...to celebrate your
15 years as James Bond,
I thought we could do a
speed round of your Bond films,
and just give us
the first memory
that comes to your mind, okay?
It could be a long story.
It could be one word.
Just something
that reminds you.
Okay, let's start with this.
-Okay.
-"Casino Royale."
-Cranes.
-Yes!
-Yeah, jumping off cranes.
-Yeah. That's exactly right.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
-"Quantum of Solace."
-A lot of problems.
No, it was all good.
[ Laughter ]
It was all fine.
It was all great.
I think the
rooftop chase in Siena,
which is at the beginning
of the movie,
which was a lot of --
Before I started "Bond,"
I had a genuine fear of heights.
I mean, like, not great at all.
And when I --
I don't anymore.
-Wow!
-But I had to get up there
and sort of, like,
incrementally go higher and
higher and higher and higher,
and then, eventually,
I was sort of
leaping out of windows,
you know, into moving buses.
It was a little like, you
know, -- It was quite an arc.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-Oh, "Skyfall."
-Judi Dench.
I mean, it's easy.
That's the sort of --
-Yes.
-I mean, you know, the fact
that I got to work with her
on three movies,
and she's one of the most
glorious, delicious
human beings on planet Earth.
-She is, right?
-Yeah.
-She looks that way.
Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-And, also -- She does.
Who doesn't love Judi Dench?
But, also, I remember Adele
doing the theme on this one.
Adele. Come on.
-I mean, it's all -- Yeah.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-"Spectre."
-We did the biggest explosion
in movie history,
out in the Moroccan desert.
I don't know if we told
the Moroccan government
that we were doing it,
but all I know is that
Léa Seydoux and I
were standing there,
and we basically --
They were on our back
and they rolled the camera.
And this thing
started blowing up,
and I could feel Léa
just, like --
just leaping further backwards,
and I was just saying,
"Stay in shot, stay in shot.
We can't do this again.
We can't do this again."
-Wow!
-I mean, it was terrifying.
It was like, I mean,
this thing just rose up,
and the percussion on
your face -- it was remarkable
and kind of incredibly moving
in weird way.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-"No Time to Die."
-So many memories from that.
I don't know.
It's like the culmination
of all that.
That's what I'd say.
I mean, that just -- This exists
because of these four.
-Yeah. I can't even begin
to thank you enough,
as a fan, just of movies,
but also of James Bond,
what you added to the character,
the way you, like,
reinvigorated the franchise,
the fact that
when you made him --
You made him extra-human,
and I think
this last one, people are gonna
flip for your performance.
I thought maybe --
-Can we have a drink now?
-I had to.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I had to.
♪♪
I'd be honored to share a cheers
to a martini with you.
Mr. Bond, Mr. Craig,
thank you for everything.
-Cheers to you.
-15 years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. That's not bad.
-That's not that bad.
-That's not bad.
-Daniel Craig.
"No Time to Die" is in theaters
and IMAX right now.
We'll be right back with
Meghan Trainor.
Stick around.